durant les vacances scolaires mascarin
jardin botanique de la réunion propose
divers ateliers animations pour les
enfants
notre grand coup demain ateliers
ludiques sur le thème d'aidé comme inès
l'atelier là c'était donc une chasse aux
trésors l'ancien découverte ludique du
jardin botanique et l'objectif c'était
de découvrir en fait toute la magie des
légumineuses et surtout de comprendre en
fait que de cette famille végétale
regroupe toutes les plantes qui ont un
point commun c'est à dire qu'elle
possède un fruit en forme de bouche
voilà que la finalité du jeu c'est de
découvrir ce point commun la ça permet
de transmettre quelques notions en fait
de biologie végétale tout en s'amusant
l'année 2016 a été déclarée année
internationale des légumineuses par les
nations unies une vingtaine d'enfants du
service social de la mairie de sainte
suzanne ont pu découvrir les
spécificités de ces espèces très peu
connue des plans partiels le grand et
choix des remises en bas on a cherché
eux la famille des légumineuses
ils ont tous eu des coups c'est chouette
les croque-morts ifaty vous pour aller
chercher tous
par ce matin on affine chasse au trésor
sur la découverte du biplan ouest voie
du sabre on a des coups de plans qu'il
te connais pas c'est impressionnant
quand même devoir eux comme il nous a
dit avec un petit peu ou pas va être
vraiment grand et gros c'est tout et
nouba on a quand on nous dit une graine
d'un animal tout petit train qui sait
peut être fier tout haut que bella en
fait c'est beaucoup de choses cachées
optique court voilà ça ça aide à avoir
une autre image enfin de voile à
découvrir chaque enfant est reparti avec
une plantation de légumineuses en guise
de souvenir